dès 8 heures bernard d'euros investi le
château de versailles le lundi jour de
fermeture au public
il connaît bien les lieux puisqu'il y
travaille comme horloger depuis 18 ans
en une demi journée j'ai fait à peu près
le tour du château puis après le trianon
aussi mais bon ça dépend aussi des
horloges parce que quand j'en ai
liquidés régler ou qui marchent plus
faut quand même se pencher sur son cas
bernard brault s'occupe des 75 horloge
du château de versailles
une démission de l'horloger les
remontées il débute avec cette horloge
créée par jean baptiste bâillon on
trouve des éléphants figure phare de
l'époque
là j'ai relancé l'horloge et là je la
remets à leurs homards étant à chaque
sonnerie dans l'appartement du roy
bernard drouot montrent les poids de
cette pendule à plusieurs fonctions
toutes les trois semaines
cette partie là permet de faire
fonctionner d'activer tout un système de
de transmission qui déclenche qui font
marcher tout le calendrier dans l'anti
chambre de l'appartement de la reine une
autre horloge du xviiie siècle a une
particularité les cadres en duo donne
l'heure le cadran rond en dessous
indique la date
le joaillier veille sur le mécanisme
délicat d horloge il les regarde les
inspecte et s'attarde sur cette horloge
automates offerte en 1706 à louis xiv
qui fait partie du salon mercure cette
horloge ne marche pas continuellement
si tout le monde sait qu l'horloge
fonctionne ça c'est cool
tout le monde va rester ici en attendant
que leurs neurones et donc c'est
l'émeute et la hauteur des poids est
très faible
donc si on voulait que l'horloge
fonctionne continuellement fort et cela
remonte au moins une fois par jour
horloger un métier transmis de
génération en génération bernard drouot
travail dans la société familiale depuis
ses 20 ans il est toujours aussi
minutieux toutes ces horloges ont quand
même
imum deux sens entre 200 et 300 ans ce
sont les petits détails mais déjà
beaucoup au bruit le bruit c'est très
important
le battement du balancier et le bruit
qui en résulte c'est on sent si
l'horloge est en bonne santé quoi sa
santé bernard gros l'entretien avec ses
nombreux déplacements dans le château de
versailles la porte grince un peu normal
du château bernard on connaît bien les
lieux depuis 18 ans et ses anecdotes et
7 les 40 ans de beaumarchais c'est une
famille d'horlogers dont le célèbre
beaumarchais qui étaient engagés
également comme sa famille à arrêter
l'horlogerie pour se consacrer à
l'écriture aux lettres les dessous du
toit abrite l'ancienne forge de louis
saez à côté de la tringlerie elle
s'occupe de l'horloge de la cour de
marbre placée en extérieur
elle a été réalisée en 1769 c'est la
seule horloge ou leur montage est
automatique
on voit comment se taire avant sur les
tambours les trois mots qui allaient
vers un câble d'acier comme ça et les
pois donc va remonter l'horloge toutes
les semaines pour que ça puisse
fonctionner en 2000 le dispositif a été
électrifiée avec des chaînes de vélo et
des moteurs électriques
les poissons remontée et l'horloge est
autonome il faut toutefois la mettre à
l'heure comme les autres horloges dont
s'occupe bernard d'euros il travaille
aussi au sénat et au palais de justice
de paris